there are no heights queer people can't
reach literally
hello and welcome to an episode of
historical icons who weren't actually
straight today's icon is sally ride she
was an astronaut physicist tennis player
and the first american woman to go to
space known for her wit and cool
composure she broke gender barrier after
gender barrier and several male
dominated fields and she was gay
up first
sally kristen ride was born in 1951 to
dale and joyce ride dale was a political
science professor and both parents were
presbyterian elders no small feat for a
woman in that era joyce once responded
to a question on how she had raised such
strong ambitious daughters with a laugh
saying in a way you could look at it as
neglect dale and i simply forgot to tell
them that there were things they
couldn't do as a child ryde was
ambitious bright and extremely good at
tennis but gave up her plans to go pro
to focus on school fascinated by lasers
and physics ryan went to several schools
eventually landing at stanford
university in 1973 where she earned a
bachelor's and master's in physics and a
doctorate in astrophysics she also
picked up an english degree you know
just for fun and her last doctorate year
1977 she saw an ad in the school paper
for nasa and out of 8 000 applicants she
was picked by nasa as one of only six
women astronaut candidates to join what
became known as the 35 new guys
dang sally you are a badass
unfortunately sally and her fellow
female trainees had to handle their fair
share of sexism sally answered sex's
press conference questions with humor
and composure returning at one point why
doesn't anybody ask rick those questions
described as a reluctant role model ryde
was often surprised that people were so
curious and impressed with her
accomplishments seemingly just because
she was a woman
saying it may be too bad that our
society isn't further along and that
this is such a big deal
on june 18 1983 she became the first
american woman and the youngest american
ever to go to space the 1983 challenger
mission was six days long during which
she probably did a bunch of cool flips
oh and also deployed two communication
satellites and carried out a variety of
experiments on earth's atmosphere
in 1984 rides served on the second space
mission aboard challenger this time she
had a friendly face on board her
childhood friend katherine sullivan who
became the first american woman to walk
in space these women were literally out
of this world
in january 1986 ryde was on the ground
training for her third space mission
when an unthinkable tragedy occurred the
challenger launched exploded killing
everyone on board
ryde was subsequently appointed to the
presidential commission to investigate
the accident after the catastrophic
event nasa suspended shuttle flights for
more than two years
in 1987 raj decided to explore new
adventures and left nasa she taught
physics at the university of california
and wrote and collaborated on multiple
children's books on space she founded
sally ride science an organization that
encouraged children especially young
girls and minorities to pursue science
math and technology saying simply you
can't be what you can't see
ryde was diagnosed with pancreatic
cancer at age 59 and died at home on
july 23 2012.
now on to the queen
bride was married for five years to
fellow astronaut stephen hawley and she
also privately identified as a gay woman
ryde preferred to focus on her
profession and never made any public
statements about her sexuality when ride
was diagnosed with cancer she and her
life partner of over 27 years tam
o'shaughnessy decided to be more open
about their relationship becoming
certified domestic partners in
california and introducing each other as
my partner it was only in her obituary
written by o'shaughnessy with ride's
blessing that ride officially came out
to the public for the first time the
public learned more about ride's
personal life and her long-term
relationship with tam a children's
science writer professor and former
professional tennis player they became a
couple in 1985 two years after sally's
first historic space mission although
they had first met while playing tennis
when they were 12 and 13. i guess love
does mean something in tennis after all
ry's obituary shocked the nation
remember the fight for legalization of
same-sex marriage was raging at this
time and the national marriage equality
act wouldn't pass for another three
years in america some thought it an
outrage and others celebrated the
discovery of a new lgbtq icon
in spite of her fears about how her
sexuality would be perceived support
provide came out tenfold after she died
sarah mcbride told space.com that ryan
demonstrated to the world that lgbtq
people can be astronauts and that we can
be a part of every single field and
industry and that we can do incredible
things in those jobs and in 2013
president barack obama posthumously gave
ride the presidential medal of freedom
accepted in person by o'shaughnessy
o'shaughnessy said ryde struggled
internally with accepting her sexuality
while working at nasa not wanting to
hurt the organization by probably coming
out she referred to the presentation of
the medal as her and sally's national
coming out saying she was grateful for
the posthumous recognition riot is still
the first and only acknowledged lgbtq
plus astronaut although she wasn't
publicly out during her lifetime ride
always pushed for inclusion she always
advocated for representation in male
dominated careers to both o'shaughnessy
and ride not having role models while
growing up was difficult tam stated that
having role models that are visible in
our society and around the world is
priceless
ride shows the less represented that
they too can reach greatness and follow
their dreams
acknowledgement for ride's achievements
have only grown as the years go by she
will be one of the first women featured
on quarters beginning in 2022 and a
biopic titled ride to be produced and
directed by joey soloway is currently in
development
in conclusion
so there you have it sally ride went all
the way to space but will forever be
remembered for who she was on earth her
legacy opens the door for all of us who
come after her and that's truly stellar
check out another episode of historical
icons here